if I'm gonna be genuine than to share my
sort of thoughts what I learn and sort
my journey I want to be completely open
and honest and that involves sharing the
good parts and also they're not so good
parts now it's easy to share the times
where where things are going well I'm
happy all that sort of stuff but I
wouldn't share something on the weekend
where I did I was quite sad about it and
that was also moot along them and I'll
move of a friend which is really nice
and nice someone well here already but
it's really apparent on the weekend when
the Sun was out I saw people with their
groups of friends there
I couldn't just text my groups group of
friends who I'd absolutely love to see
and spend time with and and plan
something at the moment my social circle
is non-existent so it was just a bit of
a thought we're like oh [ __ ] I'm
actually here on my own with one friend
and we have to put ourselves out there
and it was really just a bit of
realization and I was a bit like [ __ ]
and I was like okay this is real and
yeah I can get what people can get
really anxious about that